thank you for tuning in to the dean show
always exciting exciting every week a
brand new show a brand new guest
and with us today we know that according
to the guinness book of world records
it's the world's fastest growing
religion islam
this way of life that brings peace
prosperity purpose gives you purpose
what's the purpose of life is it to
acquire a lot of mel wealth money
entertainment numbing your mind with
music
movies and then what
that's it that's all you got
but this person
went beyond that he was searching for
the truth
and he found it but guess where you
won't believe it this is a surprise my
next guest accepted islam back in 2003
he was an mp for the u.s army we'll be
right back with the surprise guest here
to tell us this story don't go nowhere
[Music]
this is
the angel
[Music]
this is
and back here
told you surprise
terry holbrooks the author of trader how
you doing alhamdulillah it's a pleasure
to be here
i'm really excited you know some people
buy a japanese car
and we we buy chinese every day don't we
but they don't we don't get people you
know driving mercedes-benz german car
but when you you know when you
when you buy a car you buy a product or
any of these things from a foreign
country people don't consider you a
traitor do they
hell i guess that's the difference
between a religion and a car but i mean
this is even more important most
definitely and you came to this
beautiful way of life the way of life
that jesus lived jesus was a muslim he
submitted to the will of god in 2003 but
the surprise was i said you accepted it
in a place
that is a scary scary place it's out
there in cuba right correct
tell us about this
in 2003 tell us the story let's go way
back then but you know what before we
even go to that we're not going to
reveal the place some people have heard
your story many people haven't
what were you before you accepted islam
your parents were practicing christians
uh my biological parents were religious
and the slightest
when i was seven i would live with my
grandparents due to them having just
difficulties with each other my
grandfather was catholic and my
grandmother was protestant and being
that neither one of them felt that one
religion was better than the other they
didn't tell me that i should be a
catholic or a protestant they told me i
should think for myself i should study
the religions of the world and i should
make my own decisions most people aren't
even thinking about religion you heard
me open the show i said look they're
talking about partying i'm in the mind
with music entertainment right strip
clubs
uh parties social gatherings it's all
about fun fun fun you know and those big
that those big uh parties are fun big
side effects drugs
you know uh people are just all over the
place unwanted pregnancies unwanted
pregnancies stds all sorts of
corruptions out there and people are
just still suicidal from all this fun
right xanax and all the other things i
mean how did you fl i mean did you go
through this phase in life
i had a rebellious streak for a while it
was about the time that i turned 18 that
that it just wasn't going to happen i
put myself through high school and i got
out of there early i went to a trade
school the conservatory of recording
arts and sciences
i was 18 years old i'd already
accomplished this and was sitting around
doing nothing was going down that path
that you're talking about and
that wasn't what i wanted that wasn't
the future that i wanted
i looked on the television and of course
television was in full swing with the
recruitment commercials for the army you
know 9 11 it happened and
they needed soldiers so i thought to
myself
that's probably a good step i can get
some discipline get some structure in
order and it'll look good on job
application for the rest of my life
muhammad ali accepted islam he was not
considered a traitor was he he was the
world famous boxer he's gone down in
history
as one of the greatest athletes of all
time
and the list goes on so many people to
mention huge is one of them that came to
mind
but why did you call your book traitor i
mean were your peers now you went to the
army just because you be you you were
someone who chose to submit to the
creator not to the creation that's what
a muslim is
abraham was a muslim he was not a jew or
christian he was one who submitted to
the will of god he didn't worship
himself or jesus or monkey or stars or
sons or anything to creation you wanted
to worship the creator you became a
muslim that's what a muslim is
and you were labeled a traitor why is
that
if i could answer that question i
probably wouldn't have used it as the
name for my book
the name itself was actually inspired
from a newsweek article that came out
back in 2009.
i think within 18 hours there was 3 000
comments in that article and the
majority of them were calling me a
trader to the country a race trader
any variation of the word trader it was
used
and
the way african americans have reclaimed
a word that was used against them in a
very negative way is what i'm doing with
the word traitor you want to call me a
traitor fine i'll embrace it explain to
me tell me how am i a traitor
i'm an american
you were american correct did you now
accept in islam did you become an arab
did you change did your dna change as
well
to the best of my knowledge it's still
the same and most of us here that that
were born here i was born here i love my
country
i wouldn't want to live anywhere else
you know a lot of the things that we see
out there because we're commanded to to
invite people to good to try to
get people away from from things
that aren't good for them so to invite
people to the purpose of life and to
share this beautiful way of life so
you know there's nothing wrong with that
is there nothing i could think of yeah
so let's continue on now is is it
because you you you agreed with certain
things like 9 11 what are your thoughts
on 9 11. we know that this show that the
scholars that we've had we've condemned
it maybe you've got some because i
haven't talked to you really prior to
this maybe because did you agree with
things that happened on 9 11
did i agree with any act of terrorism no
do i agree with what the 9 11 commission
report said is what happened no
we could go on for probably a good
number of hours discussing what i think
happened on that day but uh
it's best if we just leave it as
some men did something very horrific and
they did it in the name of islam and i
don't think any conscious and and true
muslim would have done what they did
what caught my eye as more than 1 300
architects and engineers examined the
evidence about building sevens collapse
and disagree with the official report
issued by the national institute of
standards and technology i certainly am
much more open-minded about it than i
was and it is because of the involvement
of the 911 families and all these
engineers and architects you are about
to hear from architect of 23 years
richard gage aia member of the american
institute of architects and founder
of architects and engineers for 9 11
truth
now there are more than 1500
architects and engineers who say that it
could not have been brought down by
office fires
they are backed by 9 11 family members
who are calling for an
independent unbiased investigation
i'm a family member trying to find out
the answers to the murder of three
thousand plus people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated properly
please look at architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this
and there's some deep deep explaining to
do
it took some kind of consciousness
raising on my part before i was willing
to
look at the possibilities and really you
need to go where the evidence leads as
an engineer i have three degrees in
engineering i signed that petition for
architects and engineers for 9 11 truth
some time ago because the american
people absolutely need the truth of 9
11.
look at the evidence in fact i'll say
this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought forward
has got to come away with the feeling
that something has to be done
a real investigation
has to be put forward
we will never heal this country will
never ever ever forget that day
we have to demand a new investigation
i want justice here
exactly has nothing to do with islam
that's clear so whoever did it you can't
hide behind islam correct okay because
islam is clear there's no killing of
innocent men women and children to kill
one innocent man woman a child is the
same as killing every man woman in child
you got it we on the same page my
brother so let's talk about i'm still
confused what's this traitor think
we have to delve into the mind of the
average american you know the the kid
that's 19 20 years old sitting in his
mom's basement playing world of warcraft
and
then he sees an article about somebody
accepting islam in the army and he says
you know what that guy's a traitor
that's that's my critics that's my
reviews
because what you're you're supposed to
be more wait uh patriotic because you
know
you joined the military okay and you
came in as a what do they fill out in
the military like what religion you are
we do my dog tags all said atheist
atheists but your parents were christian
correct but then you became an atheist i
didn't accept what my parents accepted i
i was an atheist so you were an atheist
correct okay before now we got a little
more to talk about tell us about this
how did you become an atheist
as i said my grandparents didn't agree
about religion and they told me to just
think for myself make my own decisions
and study
so in doing that when i read through the
old testament and new testament it
didn't make any sense to me
when i'd looked through the torah a lot
of it didn't seem to make any sense to
me when i looked into the eastern faiths
such as hinduism and then
buddhism and taoism and whatnot i agree
with a lot of their principles and ideas
the same with christianity and judaism
but they just didn't strike a chord they
didn't make sense with me there's
something in those books that i just
didn't
jive with
so
taking that into consideration and
looking at history
more people have died in the name of god
than anything else any weapon of mass
destruction any disease
it doesn't compare to in the name of god
and as a result of such i i was not a
fan of religion was not a fan of
organized religion and i took a very
atheist approach towards belief i i
didn't believe in the ideas of god i
didn't believe in religion i thought of
it as a crutch
but will you consider now that you
didn't register as a christian
registered as atheist you still weren't
considered a traitor not at that point
but you became a muslim and they
considered you a traitor
amazing to me we're gonna take a break
terry we'll be right back with the rest
of your story and we still didn't
tell you the secret where you actually
accepted islam this is a mate you don't
want to go anywhere when you hear when
you hear this you're gonna it's gonna
blow your mind we'll be right back how
did in all i mean you would never expect
someone to accept islam there
what happened
wow how to summarize that one quickly
you know uh
over six months of observation and
interaction with detainees is is what
led me to islam
there were no detainees that were
actively giving me dawah there were no
detainees that were telling me that i
was kuffar that i had to accept islam if
i wanted to go to heaven you said some
arabic words now dawah mean they were
inviting you it was no one was doing
that right nobody was you're just
thinking watching correct okay and what
were you watching what were you seeing
uh just their daily uh activities what
they do on a daily basis i found it
relatively amazing that me with all the
freedoms of the world i could leave work
go have a bottle of vodka smoke a pack
of cigarettes have a double bacon and
double cheese sandwich and
go to sleep drunk and happy come to work
the next day and i was miserable
but the same people who were in a cage
for 23 and a half hours the day before
were going to be in a cage for 23 and a
half hours that day and they were waking
up with a smile
that to me told me there was obviously
something big and something important
that was the difference between the two
of us someone out there is saying like
look those are the terrorists those
people that hate our way of life they're
trying to blow us up and you're over
here siding with them what would you say
i would ask them how do you think we
rounded up 778 people so quickly
why do you think there's 778 people of
which we've sent 640 of homes they went
home already correct they were found not
guilty yeah they they were never charged
they were never charged none of the men
in guantanamo have been charged so they
got let go they they were they were sent
78 percent of the decency 78 home so
they were free of all these correct
allegations okay correct but now you're
watching these people
okay
and what happens now you're observing
them and talk to us from there please
between observation and interaction with
them asking questions and whatnot that
that's what led me
uh as you can imagine you know being a
revert to islam
you have a bunch of questions that
you're going to want to ask why do you
pray five times a day why do you pray
that way why do you pray in that other
language but you speak english when you
talk to me
you're a muslim why don't you drink why
don't you smoke why don't you eat pork
why do you hate music why do you hate
freedom what do you think about christ
what do you think about god who is allah
who is muhammad
the questions you would have is a reverb
those are the questions that i had and
more often than not the detainees would
answer them for me simply
sometimes they'd answer them a few times
until i understood
sometimes they'd answer my question with
a question knowing that if i thought
about the question they asked me i'd
realized the first question i had asked
them didn't make any sense to begin with
were the other guards asking questions
too like you
no i'm fortunate in the fact that when i
was in guantanamo i was very low in rank
so everybody else who was above rank was
delegating the work to me and then they
would go and spend time in
air-conditioned shacks and
try to avoid being outside and dealing
with the detainees
to me this was great and guantanamo
itself was a sociological treasure mine
i have a degree in sociology from asu
sociology is what drives me
and the the opportunity to talk to 778
men from 46 different countries speaking
19 different languages fits with your
degree yeah there's no way i'm going to
let that pass i definitely had to talk
to everybody i could
so you're you're you're thinking man and
at the same time were you you're an
atheist now were you still did you have
that void inside your heart and you were
searching for a truth if it was out
there
i didn't feel any void and i wasn't
searching no i just wanted to know i
just wanted to know and understand so
what was it that that that just happened
that had you take that step to become
one who submits to the will of god a
muslim probably a two-part for that the
first would have been a particularly
detainee
he gave me his quran when we were in
guantanamo and when i took it home i
started reading it with a negative
disposition already i didn't believe in
organized religion at all so to read the
quran i thought to myself here's another
book i can put on the shelf of
fictitious make-believe
it took me three nights to read the
quran and when i was done reading it i
remember thinking that it was the first
and to this date the only religious book
i've ever read that makes sense
from beginning to end it doesn't
contradict itself it's an instruction
manual for living
so that coupled with uh
one question that i asked many detainees
that that's what pushed me
i asked about 25 of the detainees in
guantanamo that spoke english
how can you believe in god how can you
think there's a god that possibly cares
about you you're in guantanamo you don't
know if you're going to go home your
family could have been blown to pieces
for all you know
how can you wake up and pray five times
a day and believe there's some god that
cares about you
unanimous answer from every detainee
that i asked was this is just a law
testing my deen
it's just a law testing my faith the
sahaba had it worse than me many people
had it worse than me if this is my test
alhamdulillah this is easy
subhanallah many people take life for
granted you have people there 23 hours a
day what what was life like
there for the
detainees
you wake up in a cage and you pray
fouger you have breakfast and you're
still in a cage
you pray door and you're in a cage you
pray azer you're in a cage
you pray magrib you eat dinner you're in
a cage you pray israel you're in a cage
there were more resolute about their
deen more adamant about their deen that
way of life they didn't give it up
become because you would think like from
your perspective someone's there and
they'd be like they would like you know
how can i be here blaming god you know
and then giving up their religion but
were people becoming more strong in
their religion from what you saw most
definitely yeah most definitely i've
actually spoken to a good number of the
detainees who've gone home and many of
them have told me that
guantanamo was was essentially it was a
heaven sent and and when i asked how can
you say that about guantanamo there's
there's no way you've got to speak to
some of the some of them that they they
met many of the detainees where like
where'd you guys be here in the states
or
it's amazing what you can do with the
internet in the internet okay
we send emails with each other i've been
to the united kingdom i've been the
saudi i've been to turkey i've been to a
number of countries so these are these
are people who got released of any kind
of wrongdoing they got sent home and you
you got in touch with them correct and
tell us what were they saying to you
again
they had said that guantanamo was a
heaven sent when i asked them you know
how can you say this about guantanamo
mozambique sansa is probably the best um
when in your life will you ever have the
opportunity to have
two years three years four years
away from your bills away from your job
away from school away from your family
and the only thing that you have is your
quran
he took that time and he made the most
of it you know it memorized the quran he
knows it inside and out many of the
detainees did the exact same thing
guantanamo for them served as a few
years away from the world to learn their
deen
their their this way of life islam their
religion
what about the horrific events that we
we we all heard we seen on the news were
you there when you know those pictures
were taken and the torture that was
going on
what you're referring to when it comes
to the pictures is actually abu ghraib
not
they're distinctly different facilities
but the torture and interrogation that
happens in those two facilities the same
so yes i was there when those types of
things were occurring
and
[Music]
i'd be a liar to say that that it
doesn't haunt me to this day i wish that
i'd done something about this when i was
in guantanamo the time to have taken
action would have been then not now but
what could you have done
been a conscientious objector no i'm not
going to do this no i'm not going to
treat these men this way no i'm not
going to participate
are are there any
people of god consciousness that did
step up
you know we we have that uh captain have
you met him captain e yeah he was there
with me he was there with me okay he's
another person that also accepted islam
he was a captain in the army right he
accepted himself he was a muslim
chaplain he's a muslim muslim chaplain
in the army yeah
so what what happened next now you're
you're talking you left there did you
accept islam at guantanamo or after you
left halfway through my time in
guantanamo i said my shahada with a
detainee
okay
so what what did that you know what we
got to take a break people are wondering
like what did that entail because some
people you know they know okay you
become a christian you go get dipped and
baptized in a big pool and stuff was
there a pool there did you have to get
baptized to become a muslim great time
for a cliffhanger yeah so we're going to
be right back to answer this question i
know you got many more i'm going to try
to ask them for you here on the dean's
show with terry holbrook we'll be right
back
[Applause]
why is our news media foaming at the
mouth when it comes to stories about
islamic terrorists
but not white guy terrorists
it's not because muslims are a bigger
threat
in fact between 1980 and 2005
94 percent of all the attempted or
successful terrorist attacks on u s soil
were not carried out by islamic radicals
but instead by non-muslims mostly white
guys
so then why the obsession
is killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious back here on the
dean show with the author of trader and
we talked about people every day
are
not many people are driving japanese
cars they're not considered traders
german cars you know chinese products
you know we love our country
but you know what we want
we love god first and foremost we love
the creator the one who gave us the eyes
that we see with
you know the air that we breed with the
one creator the creator who created
jesus moses no muslim is a muslim unless
he believes and loves jesus but never
did jesus ever claim that he was god or
he said worship him and it's an article
of faith to believe in jesus and you
obviously know that as a muslim now
you know we do what jesus did we pray to
god
we don't worship the creation we worship
the creator and you did that and that's
the part
of
the
procedure to become a muslim is to agree
that i'm not going to worship anything
in creation i'm going to only worship
the creators nothing where the worship
of god and muhammad is the messenger
when did you take that testimony of
faith the shahada they have to dip you
in a pool
i actually had many of the same
questions i didn't know if i was
going to be saying a funny prayer and a
chant if we were going to light incense
and candles if there was going to be a
bath
i didn't know what to expect but i knew
december 29th 2003 that i wanted to
embrace islam
this same detainee that gave me the
quran was the same detainee that i said
my shahada with and
at first when i had asked him you know i
want to embrace islam can you help me
with it he said no
he was very adamant about not allowing
me to embrace islam at first he sat me
down and said do you understand what
you're getting yourself into do you
understand the way your country will
look at you the way your family will
look at you your friends your army
do you really know what you're getting
yourself into and saying you're shahadah
and it like i said it was a no-brainer
to see these men waking up and being
able to smile and go through each day
and then me having all freedoms in the
world and being miserable
i wanted what they had and if the
difference between us was islam
i wanted it was this something of
obviously we can't say this was blind
faith because you really you you you
were looking at this
you know
with an open heart and open mind
obviously you were asking questions and
do you feel that most people if they do
the same thing if they take a scientific
analytical approach and they open their
heart and mind that they'll come to the
same realization that you came that this
way of life islam submission to the will
of god
is not an organized religion by man or
man but it's the one organized by the
creator
if they give it a shot not only do i
believe that i actually wouldn't want it
any other way
i i don't think that uh being out there
and being
evangelical is is an advantage i think
telling people the science and the facts
and allowing them to see the proof for
themselves
it's kind of hard to refute where the
quran came from when you when you look
into the science of it have you become a
better human being after accepting this
noun
i think my wife would say yes
i would say yes i put down alcohol i put
down smoking i put down a lot of bad
habits that i used to have i become a
nicer person a kinder person
i would say in in many ways yes islam
has definitely improved my character i
mean some people they think okay you
accept islam you become some fanatic
i mean how far away is this from the
truth i'm not leading
really leading the witness but we know i
know people that i sit with who've come
from just a scumbag life people who had
no life people who had all the money the
most academic you know people who were
at the lowest of low but when they came
to islam now like you you know your
character gets better you know you leave
off a lot of devices
you know uh what what do you have to say
to people out there the skeptics who are
like you know who are like traitor
well the
current statistic is that one in three
people in the world are
of
islam that one in three people are
muslims so if that in fact is the case
and
you think that all these muslims are
fanatics wouldn't america have a genuine
problem
wouldn't we really have something to
worry about if one in three people hated
america
i mean it should be pretty easy to read
between the lines and see if the news is
lying to us the media is lying to us
that
with just a little bit of intelligence
and a little bit of investigation
you can see that islam's not the boogie
man that it's been made out to be
that's really sad when when the actual
peacemakers the people of peace have
been made out to be the people of war
because we really are the people of
peace you know salam peace
it's in our greetings we greet each
other with us like peace be with you and
jesus by the way greeted his followers
with shalom i like peace be with you we
pray like jesus prayed we worship like
jesus worship i mean this is the same
religion it's the same way of life so
you know it's a shame that you know you
know even if you look at i'm sure you
know these statistics you know 94
percent you know if you look at the fbi
statistics the facts you know terrorist
attacks we're not perpetuated by muslims
is that is that right most definitely
yeah so what do you i mean
when people see these facts or do they
even bother looking
i don't think most people look i think
it's easier to just listen to what the
news has to say and then to watch what
the television tells you and to believe
that as opposed to doing a little bit of
research on your own
and i hate to say it but i think that's
genuinely what the truth the situation
is before we give uh because we just
gave people a taste test
about your your life but you actually
wrote this book now tell us what advice
would you have for the person that's
also in the same situation man or woman
and you know they've been to all the
parties they've done all the drugs hard
or soft you know addicted to porn not
happy you know multiple girlfriend
multiple boyfriends money i mean just
like bank accounts full of money but
they're broke in the heart right and
they just flickering through and they
caught the d show and they're like look
at these two white guys oh they're
they're muslim right but i like what
they're saying it makes sense what would
you have but they've still got this you
know this false notion about islam you
know arab in the desert things blowing
up you know what what what advice would
you have for this person before we lose
them and they turn the channel
you know i hate to be so cliche but take
a look in a book reading rainbow
i like to go back to when i was a child
um
i don't know of anybody who's ever died
from opening a book
open it up read it
that's it it's as simple as that read
study and they if they like what you
have to say tell them about where they
can get your book trader
it's available on amazon at this point
but it's a little difficult to find i
would suggest going to www.gtmo
getbowbook.com it's available for kindle
and paperback no one ever died from
opening up a book i like that well and
with that note thank you for being with
us mr terry
and we'll see hopefully sometime in the
future inshallah i'm always available
thank you and nobody ever die from
opening up a book i mean if you lost
your mother and she sent you a letter
and they told you look go to this place
where you can read it i mean i'm telling
you open up this quran get it for free
1-800-662-islam
we'll send it to you read it
don't shy away if you're listening to
the show these are the signs that are
coming from the creator it makes sense
worship the creator not as creation we
love jesus no muslim is a muslim muslim
is simply one who submits to the will of
god islam is not about terrifying
killing innocent men women and children
it's not about that
the real peacemaker has been made to
look like the war mongers this is that
false baloney phony nonsense
and if you're intelligent enough which
you are
don't let them pull the wool over your
eyes
call upon god alone
and he'll facilitate a way and go and
visit your local masjid talk to a muslim
get to know a muslim
and you have no idea what kind of world
can open up for you of goodness
because you can't buy a six-pack a piece
peace is something that we're all
looking for purpose
purpose don't you want to know purpose
well you might have found it but if you
turn away hey
then you really be broke and you don't
want that do you so do something do
something honorable
and
visit us here every week on the dean
show
same time same channel until next time
until then peace be with you